so we responded with it with the
appliances from cheshire final rescue
service and they were supplemented with
our colleagues from derbyshire final
rescue service Greater Manchester Fire
and Rescue Service and staff at your
final Rescue Service and through
combined efforts we were managed we very
quickly managed to establish accordin to
protect the scene and to deal with the
incidence my colleague Steve Barnes will
go into the details of some of that for
you shortly all i want to say at this
stage is that we are still dealing with
four unaccounted people we believe they
are still somewhere in the building and
we will endeavour to where deal with
that issue in a few hours time once we
get the incident under full control
there are a significant number of
hazards that are presenting themselves
to us as we deal with the incidents and
we are being very able supported by our
colleagues from Cheshire Police
Northwest ambulance service the West
Midlands Ambulance Service and
specialist teams from across those for
fire and rescue services that have just
mentioned so hand over to Steven are to
give you some the detail in terms of the
operational response